what is happening region ignition I'm
Greg Alba when do you leave when you
leave from Collider videos he is on the
movie couple channel that is her
personal channel she runs with her
husband actual name is Dustin hi I know
it I've just been lying all these other
videos so heard us and do a lot of
reactions and reviews on bitter but
today we're not doing a reaction we're
going to just share our opinion keep
that in mind
opinion this is our favorite list of
female action characters this is not the
word also subjective objective not back
to long insisted layer or penis come
from a horse who comes to mind when I
say kind of hard to like when we had to
put a number to a name it was actually
pretty hard like your heart you know we
have to think about it for a little
solid 60 second we thought with atomic
blonde coming out this weekend that we
would cover this list specifically we're
ten and a couple of honorable mentions
that will give a for number one
unveiling number ten on our list we have
Scarlett Johansson's not Lucy even
though some people are going to give us
crap we got Black Widow Black Widow now
Black Widow to me is such an interesting
part of the MCU because you haven't had
her own standalone movie is she's such
an integral part of the whole Avengers
community iron man - yeah dude she I
thought she was fantastic in that movie
I don't really like Iron Man - but she's
kicking butt in that in that action
scene that she had that's the scene
everyone was talking about that people
really enjoyed about it you know what
was funny is when I saw that movie and I
saw her first she had to curl your hair
I enjoyed her action seeing obviously
but I did not like her overall look it
wasn't until the Avengers movie where I
would like when you don't end up in a
chair and I was her opening scene I was
like yes Black Widow Scarlett Johansson
you could just put her name on here
aside to me with what stuff like Lucy
even just in the shell I think yeah
Black Widows the one that got her all
this work in terms of being an action
star and they keep evolving her
character in all the right ways and
she's someone that fans are petitioning
to have our own standalone movie for a
reason coming to you at number nine it
is a hit
girl first Enid kick-ass the most
cussing ever yeah well yes she was like
how is she in that I think she was 13
when she filmed she supposed to play
like a ten-year-old
so what cussing I loved her in that
movie when I was making this list we
originally just had five names I had
like my own five and he had some names
that we made it into a top ten I was
like I have to have Hit Girl in this way
because she steals the show in that
movie for me and I mean everyone's great
in that film but Hit Girl specifically I
remember when I saw that movie in the
theaters I was like that is the most
badass little girl I've ever seen and
surprisingly believable I wanted to
cosplay as or as soon as I saw you I'm
like who is that and can I get more I
roleplay with my girlfriend and it's
disturbing I'm Big Daddy she's hit curl
and I remember like we shouldn't do this
Wow he thought the relationships number
eight Leeloo dollars multipass her
actual man basically before she was
Alice and Resident Evil she was the
fifth element remember watching that
movie like when it first came out it had
been out for weeks and my friends didn't
trying to drag me to her I wasn't loving
you love it I'm like a hatter knows I'm
into these kind of moves out and then I
thought I'm like visitors but nothing
ever I just remember her doing that
front flip and then she kind of she's
like oh yeah yeah we're just fighting
all those people those like alien
creatures yeah yeah one thing all these
action heroes have in Commons are all
like sexy in their own way now but she's
way more than just sexy in that it was
interesting to see her come onto the
screen she's like a white girl who can
really kick ass yeah she's kind of a
quiet character but she's ooh she's also
a full-fledged character she wasn't just
a person who fights
she was actually someone who you really
got the care for and called the fifth
element
everyone only tuned in because the retro
lupus on a starburst Willis yeah but
then you end up walking down the
movie-going she's great yeah I mean I
remember the character when you when she
was in the back of his taxi when she's
fallen in and she was like please help
please help us she had tears in her eyes
and I fell for her and he obviously has
character did too because no he fell in
love you like helped her out yeah
entire life change loved an orange hair
oh yeah man yeah without there was no
fifth element there would not have been
the remarkable Resident Evil franchise
super green super awesome so number
seven we've got furiosa from Mad Max yes
definitely I feel like after seeing that
movie I want the ethereal as a
standalone movie absolutely I mean
that's what everyone's been wanting to
everyone's expecting a furiosa
standalone movie this is another
performance in this list she's not the
credited star of the movie how'd you
hear Mad Max fury road everyone really
cares more to tune in to see Tom Hardy
playing Mad Max yeah when the movie is
done while everyone's talking about the
action everyone was talking about pretty
Elsa and how great she was and how
empowering a female character she was
yeah and also what I loved about that
role when I saw the trailer for Tom well
I'm like this makes sense sexy female
assassin Charlize Theron she could
probably train for this movie and get
the job done but furiosa is anything
she's kind of far from being a sexy
appealing woman yeah it's a real tough
chick with shaved head yeah happen arm
and so I love that she stripped herself
down to be something that's not going
for sexy female
yes she's don't compromise as I found
her so appealing in forever cherish her
male yeah yeah oh she's strong powerful
independent and she definitely had her
own her own agenda and she was not going
to let anyone yeah you know like lead
her astray from that I want to be just
like her when I grow up
so number six on our list how could you
not include this woman Wonder Woman Oh
what more can you say I mean you've
talked about it plenty on Collider on
her own movie couple channel make sure
to subscribe there and also we talked
about Wonder one funny at times on this
channel I mean the first official like
great movie to come out of the DC EU I'd
have a universal opinion not just like
uh some DC fans like everyone thinks
that and the first great female
superhero standalone movie as well it's
an empowering movie and make me cry I
cry Michelle that battle battle get no
man's land man now
I me and John and Andrew or just we're
just sitting there was crying he goes
here who you aren't the only ones in the
audience for sure I know I know I mean a
lot of other woman crying with us yeah
maybe in common with me three times and
even the first time I saw a saw her in
that maybe Superman I was like okay now
I am excited he this Wonder Woman movie
and then Lee asked a beam you talked
closer I started to fear because I was
like she's such an iconic superhero when
you think being a superhero comics
superhero using Wonder Woman like Ronnie
that's the first person that comes to
mind I'm like how are they going to do
this I is going to be cheesy because
they think about Lynda Carter when she
deserves a little spinny around and then
you know run like it Wonder Woman it is
such an empowering movie for all ages
all genders one thing that I really
appreciate that movie too is that in a
day and age where like feminism is such
a popular topic I think out of all the
characters we mentioned this list she's
the strongest representation of feminism
in terms of equality yeah women are
better than men which is right what does
it almond acknowledge its equality yeah
number five we got the baddest chick of
them all Sarah Connor what it's like to
be a mom I think of Sarah Connor I mean
if you had a model like mom yeah okay
you know I remember her seeing her with
the shotgun she was one thing she was
like yeah oh and I was like really
insane I love art
when he wants Terminator one she's this
fragile vulnerable woman her heads not
so bad she's in just picture on her head
still not biting the second one he's
counting on this Kyle Reese guy to take
care of her the entire movie until the
very end
when she does successfully take down the
Terminator yeah but her evolution in
Terminator 2 is one of the best
performances I could think of to put on
this list because she is super
believable as vulnerable fragile afraid
woman in Terminator 1 yeah and then
super believable the second year doing
pull-ups in Terminator 2 in that mental
zone who properly by peers yeah no no
the correct term right now yes anyway
the whole performance though every line
she delivers you believe the strength in
earth is this more than just their
physical appearance yes she got the top
knot shape yes you can use the guns but
it's the way she carries herself and the
way she interacts with everybody the way
she is is a strong overprotective mother
yeah fantastic performance and also a
sense of vulnerability when she cries
after she's trying to kill miles bison
and I really felt for her you know it's
tough being a woman it is and be a
single single mom single mom I mean she
is she there there was nothing she
wouldn't have done for her son and Emily
saw in both in both movies and I love
seeing the transition the growth of her
from the first movie to the second movie
absolutely number four on the list
Beatrix kiddo the bride here we are
another strong woman mother character
this might have been wife I think Sarah
Connor was probably my introduction into
like strong female action heroes what I
think the first one I fell in love with
was in the Thurman in the bride
man what a magical experience I would I
must have been like not even a teenager
just yet when I saw it I was so wowed by
her entire performance such an
intimidating woman in that film I feel
like when I look at the list of the five
people we have like you're like four to
the five of them have a lot of similar
traits because they have everything of
being a vulnerable woman at the same
time that vulnerability provides him a
lot of strength yes not just in terms of
physicality but it's all within the
inner character the perseverance because
Kill Bill Vol 1
yeah she's kicking ass the whole time
she's an unstoppable machine but a part
fits where you see a lot of it come from
the inside where you see her training
and the grueling process she goes
through to become a lethal warrior which
is in the coffin punching her way out
even when she has to finally kill bill I
mean yeah she just she has to do what
she knows she must do it even though
it's heartbreaking she has to go through
with the hardest decision right now kill
the father yes one of the most memorable
scenes was to shoot what she had a
run-in with the crazy 88 right and and
that was I remember just seeing that and
for the first time ever I was like the
best acting whatever an action star like
the bride that was in the Bruce Lee
inspired
jumpsuit
I would say would Kill Bill Vol - she's
probably the most layered performance
out of them all but she's still number 4
for our personal list for number three
we opportunity from the matrix you'll
see his face but is very much about her
and Neal and their interconnections
that's an important point she says a
port marked a whole neo mythology and
everything like that
what I like about Trinity is that it's
on the front and I feel like this is
kind of very similar to some of the
other women we talked about she's so
stone-faced
she's very own especially when she first
meets Neal it's like okay she still
thinks she's so businesslike
it wasn't until then were you like oh
they she does have emotions and feelings
so when they fell in love it was I think
way more effective than it would like oh
yeah oh he has to be the love interest
she was the girl in the movie she is
definitely basically the supporting
character - Neal in this movie but she's
such a standout character in it and I
think out of everyone on this list
except for our number one she's the one
who can probably really fight this yes
like yes the amount of him - but yeah
yeah oh yeah Annie a Jovovich the kind
of fighting and the stunts that she does
in the matrix the preparation she did
six months of training for that movie
and the additional year of training for
the sequels yes like holy crap this
woman can really throw down and she does
have that presence in general but she
also has the loving supporting nature as
well every man wants a Trinity in their
life I want to [ __ ] in my life I
remember the first time I saw and I was
like okay I need sunglasses
I need trench coat I need a cool
motorcycle helmet and how to learn how
to learn how to do a scorpion cake yeah
did a movie and I was like yeah
all right so number two on the list how
could you not have this person and then
ripped a Ellen Ripley to me is the most
similar to Sarah Connor I find on the
okay so for the faculty I mean yeah she
technically is a mom and when you did
they establish an aliens and you see
those motherly qualities as she has been
you in that movie but she's another
character who I feel she starts off
stronger than how Sarah Connor started
off but in aliens specifically that role
she is someone who is terrified and
traumatized
she's absolutely traumatized and I find
it to be the most fascinating aspect of
her because the whole movies about her
facing her fears yes and by the end
she's the one who conquers you know
she's the one who's able to bring Newton
Hicks to be able to survive yes that
version part three and how that round or
not but in particular in that aliens
movie there's so many memorable parts
you know get away from about are you my
cat's all the time
oh no exactly what you said just just to
echo on that was the first time I saw
her just with an alien coming at her and
everything and she's just closing her
eyes in a complete sphere and she's
frozen in fear in that situation in a
situation that no one want to find
themselves in and she conquers it and
she fights old mom and she survives at
that point Jed a choice you can either
get killed or she didn't try and survive
and she picked a ladder and I feel like
a lot of these characters start off in a
reasonably strong place from the movies
we're listing them from you know Trinity
starts off already able to find all her
stuff but Ripley was someone who really
had to grow into this character in the
course of one film and that's why I will
put her as number two so before we
available our number one pick for the
day will give some honorable mentions
and these are more actresses and to me
they didn't really have like the roles
that could be at like performance right
but they've definitely done enough
performance exactly call them action
stars yeah for sure so on the list we
have you know of course Angelina Jolie
films like salt
Tomb Raider wanted hello mister missus
misdeeds of the attachment where she
heard Brad Pitt brought it out was yeah
I'll be his thing ever oh dude yeah and
they are so happy together now to
Michelle Rodriguez I mean she was just a
transgender hitman or something one of
that movie she wasn't really I don't
think I do notice I think of her and I
think of while she was in loss and then
very and fast and furious and she's in
the Resident Evil franchise today and of
course Zoe Saldana
you know you get colombia colombia
colombiana the more avatar she's always
she's rushing in the first part of the
Caribbean do a lot away at that and you
know we have zhang ziyi on the list you
know I think Tiger and Emerson he did
great in that movie rush hour to Tiger
much of like Hong Kong totally yeah yeah
she's fantastic
sofia boutella she's also into Thomas
lon and she has a Parkway party movie
with Charlize a mummy and of course
Kingman Kingsman oh yeah wait wait lady
so those are our honorable mentions but
our number one pick Wendy leader you
like to remember I was going to general
for you all drumroll all right number
one and she is that so many roles that
we sell HTP she just say her name
Michelle go show yo yo yo yo I know you
give a list feel about her on Collider
and the spiders most kind of same thing
yeah I grew up in the time of the early
90s I was really invested in the Hong
Kong cinema there was Jackie Chan um
meow
Sammo hung gently and then there was
Michelle Yeoh yeah Michelle Yeoh was
pretty much the female Jackie Chan she
did her own stunts she could really
fight she's a powerful actress she's
proven that in a lot of films this woman
can really act yet she can fight and she
looks great on camera she's fine but she
can really hack but I remember watching
the movie super cop when I was like 6
years old
everyone tuned in for Jackie Chan and no
one in America knew who Michelle Yeoh
was at that time and she was fantastic
and she upstaged Jackie Chan and a lot
of those scenes if somewhere she's
hanging on the top of the van is another
truck passers Oh IRA fine she's done
plenty of stunts you could think of and
it's hard to say one roll yes done
because she's done so many for her to be
able to really fight able to act and
able to really do her own stunts you
just got to give her like her name yeah
yeah and she's multifaceted too because
it's not just martial arts burger she
truly can actually she can be in drama
so on Hong Kong don't like you said we
see her
doing that and also like one of the most
memorable things and this is kind of
newer but in Crouching Tiger Hidden
Dragon where she won't take us out with
the evening yeah and they not only you
know show off their martial arts and
wirework skills they went through like
50 different weapons in that one season
to both have more able to utilize them
fully so I think that's just really
present the training that goes into it
she was the first Asian Bond girl I
don't remember all the Bond films to the
greatest as well as I should but I do
remember feeling this seems like the
first Bond girl who could really fly you
know she was he she was super believable
in it she does her own fighting in that
film yeah Crouching Tiger I feel like
she should do more American films but
she does do American films see she tends
to do performance-based you know Memoirs
of a Geisha sunshine
she likes to stick I checked it
discovered everyone superstar that
Michelle Yeoh easily the number one for
both of us that's for sure
I know aren't we like artistic filmmaker
picking them why would you don't have a
good person at night just opinions just
the same maybe they can make their own
list in the comment section yeah oh yeah
yeah it'll do the YouTube interactive
thing what are you coming your favorite
action female lady's stars characters
you know you know the question what do
you think of our list
do you like what you see or you want to
see more click right here's pretty good
that was pretty good that's brutal
really does not we're doing why don't he
ever goes too far yeah well Wendy I
appreciate you being here thanks for
having me tons of fun with you oh the
fact that you are a woman that you would
be here to talk about women women women
women women women women we met on this
video would be very much appreciated
that you're here please make sure to
check out Wendy on her channel the movie
couple channel with her and Dustin
Hoffman where they are doing reactions
and reviews and they are so good
together
wonderful personality yeah she's on
Collider videos but make sure silent
mode
Tanna subscriber the real rejects quit
that notification bell